加部さんこんにちは
という紹介する木があります東京大学で
都市計画というもの
阿蘇の研究
伸びようとする
今日テープスプリングで部分ちょ
花粉症がひどいです
嬉しいところがあるかと思います
すごいご了承していた
1まず僕のやってるよ
プロジェクトから紹介していきます
皆さんの買い物フェイ者対応弱者という言葉は聞きになったことがある
の頃写真
マール育休ところはお店がもいません
バスに音の先発があるんですけどちんちんに3本 a
見てるところも限られています
もちろん高齢になってくると車乗れないかと思っているので
欲しくなって困っては厳冬期
この地域ではそういった方に対して住民の方読んで女性なんですけども
主錨のような移動販売して
最後のを待っての牙地域に作っ
で今回のくるおばあちゃんたちが組めばいい
あおしゃべりしながら今お茶飲みながら待っていると思うんですけど
ヨハンが避けるのも楽しいんで
例えば移動販売終わったあともそこで買い物したお菓子が入っています
今皆さんが訳あって少しお茶会はならいいか
今の季節ですと鼻が冴えてくるとじゃあの花火をして帰りますか
もちろん買い物の場っていうのも大事なんですけども
それに付随してここに来ると友達とい近所の方がおしゃべりができるような
まあふれあいの場というか交流の場楽しみのバッテリーもなっている
でこれがすごく大事なんかおっ
終わったらこういったふうかっていうものが今後マヨ持続的な
表すなっているとかされて魅力的になっていくかって方法を考えていろいろ活動をして
います
例えばこのような
園地懸賞品大蛇空間をし辛い
まあ
準備の方がやりやすいような改定もアップいます
車しては少し改造して販売しやすいした
いうことを心得ています
ってこれは島根けれどけどももう少し山の中ですね
で限界集約ということも起動となっていう感じですけれども
すでにこの赤い地域では誰も住まなくなってしまう終了っていうのが既に存在します
もちろんそこでも飼い方に困っている方がたくさんいてこういったよう販売ものをみな
さん利用しながらストレッチです
この地域は本当に山の中で40年ぐらいいろんな業者さんが自分の縄張りみたいな形で
衣料販売してみ
2回もご提供していますよ
まあ改めて調査をして客観的に見てみると
なあ針の間にやっぱり誰も行けてないよ好き前で空白製だそうで
あそれは今行政と一緒に把握をしてじゃあ通り移動販売業者さんと連携して
コントロールしているとそういった地域が減っているのか
買い物バックローいろんな地域に
している分からないと言う
この地域はですね
同じさんが200m 300m もっと遠いん
よくあることでこう言って移動販売が1件入っ
お宅を訪ねてそこでおしゃべりしながら帰ります
なので
増産で業者さんが実はこの住民の方々の健康状態してすごく委員会幹事特急
例えばこのおばあちゃんなんかまより歩き方が悪くなったじゃないか
まあ毎週同じもたくさんか少しボケてきちゃっている
わかるんですね
声はん
一つ愛しな見守り地域の見守りとしてすごく重要かなと思い
けども
一方でその業者さん自身は江一派の完治してもどうやって対応していかなくなります
そこでパリの行政と連携しながらそこに地域包括支援センターやっぱ人正規車
かそういったものを連携させることで自動販売を軸にした地域の見守り
ってものができる著
ぱそべに従って皆さんも行政と連携することでもう少し販売しやすいような環境という
者はそれなられる
ちょっと今山の方楽しいをしてしまって行ったことがないかというあんまりイメージが
わかないんですけれども
通期のこの写真はまさに橋はの端から3キロぐらいですね
たところに
郊外型の銃な性質です
で実はこういうところにも買い物弱者ということ
は競って
こういった住宅街で一斉に家をさせて一斉に同じような世代の人が買って
いねえ姿勢に投資をするので今まさにんこれから一気全員が高齢者とし
状況に陥っていません
もちろん今車をみなさん運転できるんですけども
それゆえに地域の商店は商店街地帯すぎ対してしまったよ
あっ合わせろセットと縮小されてしまったいっていうことは
あと10年ぐらいですよね先を考えずと者車に乗れなくなりました時に
歩いて行けるところにもないじゃんよー状況になってしまう
そういった将来のことも考えながら住民の葛藤とかやって地域の中でみんな顔を合わせ
てみんなが集まりなんです
ここでん
いうふうに私もしています
でこういった住宅街っていうのは実はあまりパークにスペースではなくて
これは個人とお庭ですね5人分ステキなお庭を使ってそこでこれがまたはすごくの
ワークショップ幕作りワークショップです
いうのもふぁい草木染めだっ
燻製みんなで作った
楽しめそういったようなプログラムをプライベートな空間なんですけどもそこに挿入し
てパブリック5月
ことが辺から有効だと将来的なそこに
生活サービスみたところも
色で待ってくるっていう花は想定しなかったんですよね
そこにも柏の葉から2キロがちょっとまた別の住宅なんですけども大柄9ちゃって知っ
てこれから空き家とか
基地がどんどん降っ
空き家とかきちんとわけですけれどの方サイト日朴派
おもしろ警官の面を寄せない
けどもこれは学生と一緒に小学生が作りたいような日ローマというものを一緒に考え
ながら一緒に動かしながら
じゃあ基地を披露が記していこうというプロジェクトですね
こうやって住民の手でそこに行ってを加えて行ってみなければ自分たちことって必要な
空間
子どもの遊びとだったりまた災害7色になってました
を生み出していくともう少し
そういった肌に対して対応できるじゃないですかいう風に考えています
今まで色々ちょっと話していましたけれども
共通するそうすべての50点で共通して僕らが狙っているのは地域の中に人が自然に
開いていけて日
顔を合わせられる自然と集まれるような空間やっぱり大事でそれを作っていきたいなと
願っています
テプラはそれをふらっと呼んでいますあプラッター ec ケルプラップの発意店です
ただそういった場所があってもそういう場所があるだけでは何も起きません一位なら爪
を切るものかれた
みましょうん
こういう時にやっぱり何かそこに行く目的
しかも地域んと本当に必要な持ってきてものを埋め込んでいくことが効果的かなーと
思ってそれは例えば買い物だったりします
移動販売車はペーパー所が開発し汚し関空医療診療料はいい奴そう
そういったこれはこういった移動する機能ってことに着目してるんですけれどもそれを
僕らかなーかーって呼びます
その街角に何か目的ってもそーっと
おいてくれるようなとそれを素はとして受け止める知ったら
言う
この花母と暮らすとスケボーが愛では本当にいろんな地域って
ま注力していこう
そうしてるんですけども
遊びに来てどんどん走っては楽しくなってい
いうふうに思っています
で実はこれまあ頭取り組みの背景が野村二人している
御礼式人口減少社会の到来です
ただ僕自身の人口が減少すること自体は問題ではないか送って
指導人口減少をなんとかしてくに留め置くスターだった
いうプロにばかりに力を添えてしまうとが少し問題かなと思う
今ある僕たちのライフスタイルをかぶせて人口が減っていくのはまあ仕方がないかな
ただその人口減少していく縮小していくということをきちんと受け取って
じゃあその中でどうやっていた暮らし楽しい暮らしができるかということを
草さんが得た俺じゃないかなあと思う
これは今回は豊かな縮小という名前で
酔わせていただいてすいません
例えば山形の集約で30年後に
でも住まなくなってしまうことは全然あり言うと思います
まだその急になるもいなくなるわけじゃなくてもう30年かけて一人人がどんどんい
なくなって
縮小してるんですけどもその過程でやっぱり最後の堀住み続けさいます
自分が生まれて自分へっこんして自分ほども音で
大好きなこの街で最後に暮らしてい思う方があるならずいってじゃあそういった方たち
が最後まで豊かに暮らせるためにはどういうことがした掘ったけどを考えてい
その中に入っ
ももか生として何かのキャップが寄り添えるんじゃない
という風に考えています
例えば郊外の住宅地ストーサーに限ったように基地とか
空き家が増えているんですけれども
そういったものをうまく活用していくことで
例えばこういった子どもがせる広場になりたいとか
市民農園してもいいですし空き家を活用して作業スペース作業のための休憩スペースし
てい
何かうまく手を入れることで
豊居住環境性は築けています
という風に考えています
僕らしょ様かっていうのを最初
買い物着目して移動頑張れ祝意考えても若い者が高い
生きてください生活していく上ですごいベーシックっぽいかなっている
これを巻きし進めているんですけども
いろんなまあ要素ってのどんどん感じ
ことで広がりを持てるかなというふうに思っています
例えば福祉ですね
すごいて地域の見守りの場としてこういったものを断つ活用できないんです
この地域ではたとえば病院大きな病院としたら
握手なきゃ一緒でタクシーに乗って多くでだいたい1万円ん
診察の度まったりとか市尾札部薬を破った知ってるしてると逆1日過ぎてしまうと
そういうところでもいいよーってものすごく身近ではなっている
遠い存在になってしまうんですね
でもせっかく立て美容販売初の続きに的なが合わせられる
はそこに当て介護予防プログラムだそうですあ
健康相談の防腐良性と連携しながら
そういった取り組みをしていくことで
バイクそこに行けば誰かとつながっているのか誰かに思われてるみたいな安心感を得
られる
今地域拡大した場所になっていた
でそういった場所にせっかく順であればじゃあみんなですそして作って食べようなあー
地域のないかな
住民の方を
先生にして
キャスで待ってよく
そういうことが展開できるさん
これはまた別の地の農家と一緒に田中っていうものを作っている
いえばもちろんこの地域も買い物に困ってい
こともそれと同時に自分が作っ
野菜を着せ使わせながら見たくなってどうか思っん
せっかく売りに行くのか
近所の方がついて
サッカーも見たいな
食育に関連する方法おかしな
いうことで2点九回お店
まあだそう言ってせっかく集まってるんだからみんなが楽しい
止まって楽しく過ごせるような空間ということを一緒に作っていない
考えいます
今の農家撮影の最中活動している中でたまたま教育委員会の方が意思を持ってこの街で
は
じゃあ小学校とか公民さあと勉強しながら子どもたちばっかなくを作るプロジェクト
レッドかな
でおすすめ
が設計も最初アイデア出しの設計の制作も販売ロゼットを持っています
ええっ
そういった中で同じが街づくりさん勇気ハイツやっぱり
報告ができればいい
また子どもたちが非常に楽しいからやるっていうことがすごく
スナップ表現をしています
自分が相方たちのために分から町をしたら喜んでくれるし
それってなんか自分も楽しいところを過ごす now
表してくれええええそれを見た男何をいろいろ考えてもらえるかなって
非常に面白い展開たんですよね
でまぁ今まで紹介してきた地域っていうのはいい
実際縮小というのがどんどん過疎化高齢化を受けて始まってきています
もその中で住民の方でしたがやっぱりそういう縮小の中でもこういった空間があったら
いいよとか
五竜空間の街には必要ないと言うところまぁ色々考え
縮小を受け止めながらそういった動きをみせています
そこに対して僕らは自分たちのことを urban design partners
読む
でも住民の方々のパートナーとして一緒に考えて一緒に動いて一緒に街を浮かべて
いければいいから
に考えています
まあ今初の
こういった縮小の中でも
人が
足電波つまりん
逆に家がるに集まりせ顔を合わせられておしゃべりしてきたり
た
過ごせたりいう空間が非常に重要な
へ
何かそこは豊か空間からん
縮小する上でのチョイさん
いたから空間っていうものを
考えている感じです
で僕なんかは東京にすぎな
パパ弁に思います
で食べまー
まあまずで買い物できますしプールって何でも調べられますし
スカイプで答弁書同社で行っべっ
ですけども
なんかそう言って実際にこういうような自分の体を自分の写り的な
みよう9空間っていうものは
すごく大事なんじゃないか
いうふうに感じてい
ってこの形はその
それがたぶんうまく自分の地域の中に
すごいつけられていて
を貸すリンクしてるというか
自分スペイン進む員っていうことそうだった
需要ビュー髪を拭くかみたいなものがすごくリンクしていて
あ素晴らしいなと言う
けども
やっぱりその裏2を出してください
ちょっと見失ってしまう
シフ読む聞いて
あそこ今日みなさんこんいちど
いうふうに思っています
早津です
th